bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
l'actualité
notre dossier du jour est consacré à la
vaccination ils parleront aussi de la
violence chez les forces de l'ordre vous
entendrez notamment le témoignage d'un
journaliste qui a passé six mois dans le
commissariat du 19ème arrondissement à
paris
vous regardez l'inattendu et vous étiez
bienvenue à monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord à votre place je la
ramène à un peu moins que mais si vous
ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le trouve à paris vous le savez
certains événements récents prennent
parfois leur source dans le passé il
faut remonter le temps pour mieux les
comprendre
tariq al dit ludivine lopez vous avez
journaliste à la rédaction dina vous
avez décortiquer les grands titres de la
presse cette semaine
deux sujets ont plus particulièrement
retenu votre attention
ludivine c'est la météo de ces derniers
jours qui vous a interpellé
oui on a tous remarqué les températures
de ce mois de septembre sont
particulièrement chaude cette année une
vague de chaleur qui pose question pour
les experts elle serait l'une des
conséquences directes du réchauffement
climatique une réalité évoqué dans les
archives dès les années 70 mais elle est
reconnue officiellement en 1995
cette année là des scientifiques
internationaux rendait un rapport et il
n'avait plus aucun doute
regardez jusqu'à présent cela n'était
pour les experts qu'un soupçon
mais il parle désormais de fortes
présomptions
car si la tendance actuelle se poursuit
les simulations calculé par les
ordinateurs s'avéraient exactes et les
effets de cette hausse du climat se
ferait alors sentir très vite les
conséquences au niveau de la circulation
atmosphérique des vendée des cyclones la
présence de cyclones plus ou moins
importante dans les régions tropicales
pour la des conséquences hydrologique
qui sont encore plus difficile à prévoir
mais qui seraient éventuellement les
conséquences de plus importantes dont
les sécheresses éventuellement aussi là
c'est très hypothétique mais c'est ce
qui serait éventuellement le plus
redoutable des changements du niveau de
la mer la des changements au niveau de
la mer on en reparlera bien sûr alors
vous tariq
vous avez relevé cet article paru
dimanche c'était dans sud ouest
un article sur le bizutage est un mort
pendant un week end d'intégration en
corrèze et ce sujet justement des du
bizutage et des accès et bien pour
trouver des témoignages il faut attendre
les années 90 la tonnelle alors j'ai
choisi de vous montrer un extrait qui
date de 1991 c'est un extrait du
magazine d'info le droit de savoir à
l'heure on y voit bien sur l'humiliation
la violence l'alcool la nudité mais
surtout ce témoignage d'un ancien
étudiant vétérinaire en première année
un bleu comme on les appelle ont regardé
bleu gens là étaient en première année
vétérinaire à amiens il y a quelques
années après l'épreuve de bizutage qu'il
est subi
il a quitté l'école enterré sa vocation
et s'est reconverti dans le professeur
de mathématiques
la plainte qu'il a déposée à l'époque
pour qu'on lui rende justice n'a jamais
abouti
comme toutes les plaintes de ce genre
aujourd'hui il se souvient avec émotion
ils ont arrosé d'un colorant qu'ils
avaient dîné dans l'alcool à brûler pour
que le soi-disant de colorants tiennent
mieux qu'on ait plus de mal à le retirer
uniphase a priori ni indépendant de la
première ils ont approché une bougie
pour simuler le marquage au fer rouge
j'ai des brûlés au premier devient une
troisième degré selon les endroits sur
20% de la surface corporelle
à noter qu'il a fallu attendre 1998 pour
qu'une loi vienne le punir les auteurs
de faits de bizutage six mois de prison
et 7500 euros d'amande
voilà pour l'actualité des tout derniers
jours mais sinon que s'est il passé le
16 septembre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé un 16 septembre
regarder
un accord historique vient d'être
conclue à montréal par les représentants
de 46 pays industrialisés ils ont décidé
de stabiliser d'abord puis de réduire
progressivement l'utilisation des
aérosols contenant des composés de fluor
et le chlore dix minutes pas plus c'est
la durée de l'assaut donné la nuit
dernière par l'armée pour libérer les
otages français
l'homme et son épouse sont sains et
saufs l'opération s'est déroulée en
pleine mer sa présence de vous souhaitez
toujours transparent son état de santé
c'est aujourd'hui une volatilité
j'ai pas encore songé je n'ai pas de
raisons je ne va pas d'édition ne pense
pas qu'on ait enlevé un lob du cerveau
car c'est face aux côtés d'axa spatiale
85 ouvriers charpentier de berkshire
plongeurs élagueurs guide de montagne et
météorologues mais oui s'activent depuis
l'aube deux arches complète encore 10 à
couvrir et on pourra se prendre moi
peut-être dans une oeuvre d'art à
consulter les ingés regard dans leurs
douze départements au sujet du destin
qu'ils veulent adopter
voilà c'était notre adieu à la callas
sur ces très belles images
tous ceux qui aiment la musique
regretteront la callas ce soir et demain
[Musique]
c'est la question qui préoccupe le plus
grand nombre de personnes en ce moment
quand les scientifiques vont ils trouver
un vaccin contre le coc vie de la
planète entière attend bien sûr ce
moment avec impatience pourtant et c'est
paradoxal dans l'hypothèse d'un vaccin
contre le coc vie de 19 regardez 41% des
français ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner le vaccin une invention
française et une défiance qui ne date
pas d'hier livre oui la défiance envers
les vaccins est une tendance bien ancrée
en france nathanaël à la télévision elle
commence à s'exprimer autour des années
50 alors à cette époque je le rappelle
trois vaccins était déjà obligatoire
celui contre la poliomyélite la
diphtérie et le tétanos et des français
dénonçait déjà des effets secondaires de
quoi attiser la curiosité des
journalistes
écoutez nous sommes en 1959 du
professeur j'ai entendu dire que ces
vaccinations était dangereuse
est ce exact on ne peut nier que
l'injection de vaccin ne provoque
quelques réactions et dans les cas à
vrai dire fort à des accidents en fait
souvent on a imputé aux vaccinations
faute d'avoir procédé à des examens très
complet les accidents qui ne relevaient
pas un tel alors vous l'avez entendu à
nathanaël à cette époque la grande
majorité des médecins des forts de la
vaccination il ne cessait de rappeler
qu'elle était à l'origine d'un réel
progrès sanitaires mais pourtant un
progrès sanitaires vanté par les
médecins et qui ne suffit pas à rassurer
pourquoi non pas vraiment les avis sur
les vaccins restent mitigées le micro
trottoir qui va suivre
même s'il n'a pas je le rappelle valeur
de sondage en est la preuve
regardez il date de 1962 madame vous
êtes vous là qu'une action et pourquoi
bien sûr ce que je veux
pour une piqûre qui est très facile à
faire ça protège des maladies qui sont
peut-être dangereuse je suis tout à fait
contre parce que je trouve que ça
fatigue les enfants et on vaccine coup
sur coup et je trouve que
c'est pas bon je suis en général pour
les vaccinations mais je suis contre le
bcg a provoqué certains accidents chez
des enfants d'amis à moi je suis pour la
toutes les vaccinations sur le vcg voilà
le regard et les paroles des français
dans les années 50 sur la vaccination
que se passe-t-il dans les années 60
est-ce que ça continue le divine alors
dans les années 60 ça continue
mais aussi dans les années 80 les
inquiétudes persistent on est vingt ans
plus tard donc en 1980 des journalistes
retourne dans la rue et ils vont poser
exactement la même question dans les
années 60 et regarder les réponses ne
sont pas vraiment différente regard
dites moi monsieur vous êtes pour ou
contre la vaccination en 20 secondes et
pour quelles raisons
si on supprime les causes de maladies
y'a pas de raison qui est cause de
vaccination du canton de maladie
pourquoi je trouve il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir
et bien moi je suis scandalisée de voir
toutes les réclame qu'on fait à la radio
pour se faire vacciner
on ne devrait pas être oubliée il ya
déjà dédé des cas pour lesquels il
faudrait vraiment et d'autres non on a
des trucs à des prises de position bien
arrêtées pourquoi autant de défiance et
surtout pourquoi cette défiance persiste
et l otan est bien une des explications
possibles
on la trouve dans les archives au fil
des ans les témoignages de personnes qui
associe vaccins et effets secondaires se
sont multipliés à la télévision les anti
vaccins vont être de plus en plus
médiatisé ce qui alimente les craintes
très tôt les français vont aussi
s'interroger sur l'intérêt économique
des laboratoires pharmaceutiques et sur
la vaccination obligatoire imposée par
les pouvoirs publics un je le rappelle
une obligation dénoncé d'ailleurs depuis
les années 50 par la ligue pour la
liberté des vaccinations l'un de ses
membres s'explique s'exprimait en 1981
on écoute et les vaccinations sont
devenus une véritable religion d'état
jusqu'à maintenant
les gens sont conditionnés dans le
système vaccinale parce qu'il manque
d'informations la formation
des accidents ne circule pas où ils
recourent plus d'accidents que des lacs
cirgl prétendre voilà nous sommes dans
les années 80 les anti vaccins se
regroupent donc et c'est un fait divers
terrible qui vient alimenter leurs
craintes
oui c'est la mort subite en 1986
nathanaël de cinq bébés
leur point commun tous venaient d'être
vaccinées au tetra coque
une préparation qui associait quatre
vaccins en une injection
l'information est largement relayée dans
les médias
l'émission 7 sur 7 représentait à
l'époque par anne sinclair consacré une
enquête à ce sujet ces vaccins sont ils
la cause de ces mort subite
est ce une coïncidence ces vaccins sont
ils réellement dangereux peut-on s'en
passer bref faut-il ou non avoir peur
des vaccins à la faute il ou non avoir
peur des vaccins drame qui alimente
encore un petit peu plus
alors si non la peur du moins la
défiance autour des vaccins oui car même
si le lien entre la mort des bébés et
les vaccins n'est pas clairement établie
à nathanaël le doute est semé auprès des
parents écoutez ces femmes nous sommes
encore une fois en 1986 disons que ça
fait réfléchir
se demande si c'est comme ça on a un peu
peur quand même
j'ai eu mes amis dont le petit garçon
était vaccinée deux heures avant qu'elle
ait entendu l'émission ou un annoncé la
mort de petit bébé et j'ai pu me dire
ils ont pas les q pendant plusieurs
heures
parce que bon bah se disait mon petit
garçon qui peut il passer dans les
années passent d'autres polémiques
viennent ensuite alimenter cette peur
des vaccins oui comme celle sur le
vaccin contre l'hépatite b dans les
années 90 alors après une grande
campagne de vaccination dans les
collèges des cas de sclérose en plaques
sont révélés en 1995
et même si encore une fois aucun lien
n'est établi un je le rappelle le doute
plane le gouvernement décide même de
suspendre ce vaccin cette fois ci c'est
auprès des professionnels de santé qu'il
y a des doutes
écoutez ce médecin en 1998 nous avons
recueilli une quarantaine de dossiers de
maladie de la peau de maladies du
système nerveux
2 diabète maladies du sang donc c'est
une réalité s'agit-il de la pointe de
l'iceberg
nous n'en savons rien pour le moment et
puis arrive les années 2000 ludivine et
un autre média vient propager cette
défiance internet
les doutes sur la vaccination font de
nouveaux émules oui entre les multiples
témoignages les informations
contradictoires et les faits news la
défiance envers les vaccins est à son
apogée à l'ère d'internet
d'autres polémiques viendront encore
alimenter cette méfiance
il ya eu celle du vaccin contre la
grippe a en 2009
là encore certains français exprimaient
leur réticence écouter est ce que vous
pensez vous vacciner contre la grippe a
moi non je pense comme on n'a pas besoin
quoi les deux sens un nouveau vaccin
donc les effets secondaires
on les connaît voir pour la vacciner
elle oui mais
moi je pense pas je ne sais pas je
réfléchis encore voilà pour la défiance
des français à l'égard des vaccins en
attendant bien sûr qu'on ait trouvé un
vaccin sur le comique 19 merci beaucoup
ludivine on accueille notre invité du
jour autre sujet aujourd'hui dans
l'inattendu la police française souvent
admiré pour le courage de ces hommes
lors de certains événements
l'institution est aussi régulièrement
critiqué pour les écarts de certains de
ses agents et notamment des
comportements racistes alors notre
police est elle raciste pour en parler
valentin gendreau bonjour vous avez
passé six mois un filtre et c'est comme
ça qu'on dit dans le commissariat du
19ème arrondissement
c'est cette expérience que vous racontez
dans votre livre flic un journaliste
infiltré la police
témoignage d'un très fort première
question comment est-ce qu'on devient
policier en passant concours comme tout
le monde pour devenir policier vous avez
deux types de concours possible celui de
policier contractuels choix que j'ai
fait ou sinon vous devenez gardiens de
la paix en passant le concours de
gardien de la paix avant de revenir sur
votre expérience et donc sur votre livre
je propose de découvrir notre micro
trottoir un véritable signature de cette
émission tout à fait cette semaine avec
géraldine quand les l'avion s'est prêté
à un exercice nous avons repéré un
micro-trottoir de 1975 le sujet la
police et nous avons posé mot pour mot
les mêmes questions regarder à je suis
pour la baliser et au ghana il a un
volant pour davantage
[Musique]
la police je les respecte absolument pas
est ce que vous pensez ou de la police
pas grand chose
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de la
police je pense qu'elle est violente qui
a des problèmes
lice aujourd'hui qui font que les gens
ils ont plus confiance en elle on n'a
pas
tickets ou
il faut toujours donner plus de pouvoirs
oui ce que je pense de la police un rôle
qui est important néanmoins je pense
qu'elle a pas les moyens
disons de réussir ses missions et ils
ont bien du mérite voilà parce que c'est
très difficile pour eux est ce qu'on l'a
reproché aux policiers
[Musique]
est ce que vous leur reprochez vous à la
police pas grand chose
pas grand chose après je sais qu'ils ont
eu une saison que chaque profession ses
brebis galeuses mais moi personnellement
rien moi j'essaie étrangers oui alors
des fois je sais embêté par la police
qu'est ce que vous leur reprochez aux
policiers alors d'être un peu trop sur
le faciès et un peu moins sur les actes
d'avoir un comportement qui est pas
adapté
aux situations de de provoquer des
débordements
alors décalé violente est ce que c'est
votre avis pas pour moi pas pour loin je
pense que justement elle pourrait très
bien être même plus énergiques pour les
trials on dit qu'elle est violente est
ce que c'est votre avis clairement oui
clairement oui ça ya encore une fois 6
ça dépend des gens quoi moi ils ont
jamais été violent avec moi mais il
suffit que je me balade avec un ami qui
qui n'a pas la bonne couleur de peau
justement pour que ça parte très très
vite en fait c'est pas mon avis du tout
du tout au contraire il les sent
peut-être pas assez dans certains cas
oui allez je pense qu'elle est vivante
c'est ça fait partie de son rôle en
france en tout cas c'est un peu dommage
qu'on tape sur la police qu'on accuse la
police de violence alors que lé glas
pour faire son métier
c'est pas tous les policiers qui sont
violents faut pas généraliser c'est
juste toute cette institutionnalisation
du truc c'est de ce système
cette fonction de la police qui est
systémique comme on s'est organisé ça
c'est violent alors 45 ans la différence
a laissé place à la défiance valentin
est ce que ça vous surprend
ce que vous venez d'entendre non ça
montre une seule chose c'est que c'est
un sujet qui est clivant s'était déjà
clivant 1975 ça l'est toujours
aujourd'hui en 2020 les antilles ceux
qui dénoncent la violence policière et
de l'autre les gens qui sont plutôt pro
police plutôt favorable à la police à
l'action de la police et qui va dénoncer
au contraire les conditions de travail
dégradées de l'institution police est-ce
que vous avez constaté le racisme
dénoncer notamment dans par cette cette
jeune femme dans le micro trottoir il
n'existe vraiment pas bien sûr qu'il
existe le racisme dans la police mais là
où il faut faire attention aux mots que
l'on emploie ces il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé quand on parle de racisme
dans la police - de ce que j'ai pu voir
et que je raconte dans le monde dans mon
livre c'est que le racisme la violence
c'est l'objet d'une minorité de
policiers
alors on va s'attarder sur ces violences
à caractère raciste dont vous parlez ce
phénomène n'a rien d'inédit un tariq
depuis quand est-ce qu'on en parle dans
les médias on en parle beaucoup ces
derniers temps mais l'une des premières
dénonciations elle remonte à 1972 qui
est la date d'une affaire assez violente
c'est la sphère diab du nom de
mais diable alors moi médias bill a été
tuée au commissariat de versailles
l'histoire c'est qu'il rendait visite à
sa mère à l'hôpital
là bas il a été arrêté pour attentat à
la pudeur embarqués au commissariat
une altercation assez fou dans les faits
que j'ai pu lire dans les articles de
l'époque mais en tout cas il se défend
avec une chaise à coups de chaises tout
ça finit par un coup de feu un coup de
fusils mitraillettes qui est mohamed
diab a perdu la vie après ça alors sur
place au commissariat il y avait deux de
ses soeurs elle témoigné à l'époque dans
un reportage elles sont traduites par un
autre membre de la famille on écoute
lorsqu'ils l'ont frappé le monsieur diab
après une chaise et a commencé
tous les deux se sont mis à le frapper
donc monsieur la personne qui tire à se
trouver au fond de la pièce
[Musique]
la personne qui tire a appris le
pistolet mitrailleur à lui de la team à
de rester sur sa classe mais après c'est
relever leur ai demandé s'ils voulaient
tirer sur lui la personne qui tire à lui
répond cac
oui je le veux tirer sale race cette
affaire elle a été jugée en 1981 elle
s'est soldée par un non du valentin
gendreau est ce qu'une telle affaire est
encore possible aujourd'hui en france
je voudrais pas me lancer dans un
parallèle mais les dernières
manifestations qui ont été faites par le
collectif
adama traoré montre bien que la police
ait absolument mal à l'aise avec ces
questions là quand il s'agit de
violences policières
la lumière n'est pas faite adama traoré
il est décédé en juillet 2016 ça fait
quatre ans on ne sait toujours pas ce
qui s'est passé exactement et on
pourrait arriver tout à fait un non lieu
comme ça a été le cas pour ce monsieur
pendant ses six mois passés aux côtés
des agents du 19e du commissariat du 19e
ce que vous avez assisté justement voix
des passages à tabac ou à des violences
qui vous ont qui vous ont choqué oui
bien sûr plusieurs fois plusieurs fois
pour des personnes qui étaient placés en
garde à vue pour des tabassages de
migrants à trois ou quatre reprises j'ai
pu voir des migrants se faire tabasser
dans un fourgon de police
ce sont des violences policières qui se
font toujours hors hors radars sous les
radars
c'est à dire qu'à aucun moment vous n'en
trouverez traces dans les logiciels
écrits de la police ou à aucun moment on
en parlera sur les ondes radio de la
police ce sont des choses qui sont tus
et dans le cas des migrants ce qui s'est
passé dans le fourgon restera dans le
fourgon alors il ya les coups il ya
aussi les insultes d'un tarif des
insultes qui ici souvent les immigrés et
l'atari encore une fois rien de nouveau
ça ne date pas d'hier donc ça ne date
pas d'hier rien de nouveau à ceci près
que avant ce livre un valentin gendreau
on n'entendait pas ses mots de
l'intérieur de la part des agents mais
on avait quand même dans nos archives de
l'ina en tout cas on avait quelques
témoignages de personnes on va prendre
un exemple on remonte à 1984 c'est un
homme qui a été arrêté après un léger
accident de voiture était traité des
selles chadli sale arabe lâché
comédienne qui s'était fait chez nous
je fais des nations et française et je
suis là depuis 1947
la démo extrêmement violent ça c'était
avant
vous racontez dans votre livre que
désormais un seul mot est utilisé pour
définir les personnes assises et noir
arabe les migrants kelly ce mot le mot
c'est les bâtards c'est le mot générique
qui a employé par tous les policiers
avec qui je travaille dans le 19ème
arrondissement
évidemment ce que dit ce monsieur c'est
extrêmement choquant ça existe encore
aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi parce que
ces violences policières là ne sont que
trop rarement sanctionnés donc
évidemment comme il pourrait mettre un
sentiment d'impunité pour ces policiers
minoritaire mais racistes et violents
évidemment ils continuent ils ont aucune
raison de s'arrêter
il n'y a pas un moment des agents des
collègues qui dise stop à temps là ton
tu vas trop loin dans tes mots il
faudrait il faudrait que la parole des
policiers puissent se libérer et
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est la loi du silence
l'omerta qui règne
donc non ça n'a rien rien de changé eric
est ce que par le passé la police a fait
a déjà fait son mea culpa et s'est
interrogé sur le comportement raciste de
ses hommes
très peu en tout cas dans le fond
archives de l'ina toujours c'est de là
que je vous parle très peu mais il ya
quand même une archive qui m'a
interpellée elle date de
1992 pourquoi 1992 parce que cette
année-là de la fédération internationale
des droits de l'homme rend un rapport
elle fait état de violence de
comportements racistes de la part de la
police hier et ça fait beaucoup de bruit
dans les rangs des forces de l'ordre un
homme a tenté d'expliquer un peu ces
faits de racisme on les écoute tout de
suite quand le policier mal dans sa peau
effectivement ça va générer en lui des
idées qui ne sont pas les siens un bris
à la digigraphie pas forcément raciste
dans le champ où on contre une race mais
raciste il est aigri de par la société
alors valentin je vous repose cette
question est ce que la police est
foncièrement raciste ou bien est ce que
ce sont toutes ces situations difficiles
du quotidien qui entraîne de tels
comportements moi je fais pas du tout le
lien entre le mal être des policiers la
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail et des cas de violences
policières pourquoi parce que c'est
l'intégralité de la corporation police
qui souffrent de ce mal être policier là
mais vous avez seulement une minorité de
policiers qui est raciste et violente
donc le parallèle il est pas tenable
vous en parlez quand même le le
quotidien les conditions de travail des
forces de l'ordre se sont
considérablement dégradées et forcément
le moral des hommes également
c'est quand même un élément à prendre en
compte évidemment évidemment mais vous
savez cette histoire là ne date pas
d'hier
le suicide des policiers ça ne date pas
d'hier l'impuissance politique pour
faire face aux suicides de ses agents de
d'apple ne date pas d'hier non plus
jeune enfance pas de portes ouvertes où
je ne révèle rien qui n'ait jamais été
dit dans par le passé mais en tout cas
je montre avec une réalité crue sans
tabou et sans limite que effectivement
les policiers sondés sont des gens qui
souffrent sur le terrain dans l'exercice
de leurs fonctions et ce problème du sur
suicide chez les policiers aient connu
un depuis 40 ans le cnrs a d'ailleurs
étudié la question avec une année qui a
tristement marqué la profession tarik
satané c'est 1996 alors on va comparer
2010 9 59 suicide en tout dans la police
en 1996 c'était 71 suicides alors on va
mettre un peu de contexte aussi dans
tout ça à cette époque-là 1900
96 de la france sort d'une vague
d'attentats
donc le plan vigipirate mobilise des
agents sur tout le territoire
il ya une fatigue il y à déjà les mêmes
problèmes qu'aujourd'hui en plus à
savoir les bas salaires mais aussi un
manque d'écouté de la hiérarchie alors
1996 forcément les gitans beaucoup parlé
de ce problème de sur suicide
on va regarder une petite sélection
d'archivés un gardien de la paix une
femme de 48 ans a tué ses trois enfants
avant de mettre fin à ses jours avec son
arme de service qu vous vous n'avez
jamais pour ce suicide on affaire bien
souvent aux gens à problèmes ont ravi
les maux de la société
donc il est bien évident que ça direct à
risque d'exécution de ces cologix pour
nous
vue nous sommes des hommes des policiers
j'apprends que j'ai pensé aussi un
nouveau suicide mais malheureusement
j'ai pensé au sujet des autres collègues
voilà il ya aujourd'hui la situation
reste difficile puisque 25 ans plus tard
27 policiers se sont donné la mort
depuis début d'année jeudi c'était
d'ailleurs la journée mondiale de
prévention du suicide
valentin gendreau merci beaucoup en tout
cas pour ces explications je rappelle le
titre de votre livre flic un journaliste
infiltré la police aux éditions goutte
d'or l'inattendu touche à sa fin on se
retrouve mercredi prochain à 21h sur le
canal 27 et toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux de france info et dîna
bonne semaine
[Musique]